let a and B be two distinct points on
the parabola Y squared is equal to 4x if
the axis of the parabola touches a
circle of radius R having a B as its
diameter then the slope of the line
joining a and B can be so let's draw
this so let me draw my axes here that's
my y-axis and here is my x-axis and then
the parabola Y squared is equal to 4x
would look like this something like that
that would be a in the first quadrant
and then it would be symmetric around
that it would look like that so this
would be Y squared is equal to 4x or if
I just focus on this top part over here
I could take the principal root of both
sides and I get Y is equal to 2 times
the square root of x just taking the
square root of both sides is this square
root of 4x is 2 times the square root of
x this down here would be equal to
negative 2 times the square root of x so
the positive square root the negative
square root of both sides but this one
defines this whole parabola implicitly
and then they say they tell us that if
the axis of the parabola that's the
essentially the x-axis in destroying if
the axis of the parabola touches a
circle of radius R having a B as its
diameter so there's let's say let's take
two points on this parabola so let's say
that that is point a and let's say that
this is point let's say that this is
point B it is the diameter for some
circle so that's the diameter for some
circle that just touches this axis so
it'll just it'll just touch on here so
let me see if how well I can draw that
circle obviously this will not be an
exact drawing but let me try my let me
try my best to draw the circle under
question so the circle will look I can
do better job than that the circle will
look like would look like that that's my
best shot at it and then it has a radius
R so if we say the center of the circle
and obviously the diameter will
go through the center of the circle this
distance right here is R so another way
to think about it another way to think
about it this Y value this Y value right
over here that Y value is R
now let's think a little bit about the
center of this circle because maybe with
the center of the circle we can relate
the A's and the B's to the R so let me
let me define a and B so let me define
the point a let's say the point a just
for convenience let's make X is equal to
lowercase a squared if X is lowercase a
squared then the square root of that is
a times 2 then Y will be 2a so this
right here is the point
a squared 2a and let's make B let's make
be the point using the same logic let's
just say that's lowercase B squared and
I'm doing that so that when I take the
square root will become simple so the
square root of B squared is B times 2 is
2 B 2 B now let's get the coordinates
for the center of that diameter now the
center of that diameter is just the
midpoints of this point and that point
so let me write it down here the
midpoint the midpoint of a and B of A
and B the points a and B is going to be
equal to the average of the x-values a
squared plus B squared over 2 and the
average of the Y values so this will be
2a plus 2b all of that over 2 and of
course the twos cancel out and so this
is going to be a plus B that is the
y-value of the midpoint so at this point
right over here is going to be is going
to be a squared plus B squared over 2
comma a plus B now we just saw that this
this height right here is our so a plus
B this Y value right over here is also
equal to our this is equal to a plus B
right the Y value in between 2a and the
Y value in between to be right over here
to be this is a plus B
so just like that we were able to get a
relationship between a B and R so we
know a plus B is equal to R now let's
try to find the actual slope of this
diameter that's what they want to ask us
the slope the slope of the line joining
a and B can be so let's figure out the
slope of this actual line and let's see
if we can relate it to R in some way
maybe using this information because all
the answers they give us are in terms of
R so we need to have an answer in terms
of R so the slope the slope is going to
be change in Y over change in X so 2 a
minus 2 B 2 a minus 2b over a squared
minus B squared over a squared minus B
squared this is equal to 2 times a minus
B over a plus B this is just a
difference of squares a plus B times a
minus B the a minus B's cancel out the
slope of the diameter the slope of the
line that we care about is going to be
it's going to be 2 over a plus B it's 2
over a plus B now that's clearly not one
of the answers we need our answer in
terms of R but we just figured out the y
coordinate of the midpoint which was a
plus B that is equal to R so this is the
same thing as 2 over R so the slope of
this line right over here
the slope of this line is 2 over R 2
over R now you might be tempted you
might be tempted to say okay it's the
answer is C but and I actually probably
should have told you this at the
beginning of this video in case you
wanted to pause it and try it yourself
is that this is actually a multiple
multiple correct answer problem so you
can actually have multiple choices here
so we want to make sure that this isn't
the only answer and it's not the only
answer because we could have put we
could have put a here and B here and
drawn the circle like this and drawn the
circle essentially the exact same circle
but in the fourth quadrant so I could
have drawn the circle like this and then
I would have been dealing with the
slope of this diameter would be in
question and you can see everything is
symmetric it's just flipped around the
axis of symmetry it's flipped around the
x-axis whatever is the slope up here the
negative end is going to be the slope
over here so this is also a potential
slope so this is 2 over R then this
slope over here is negative 2 over R so
this is also an option and just just
based on the reasoning we just did you
could have ruled out two of these if you
knew that this slope is a you know or if
you know that this slope up here is
going to be I don't know if this slope
up here was going to be R then this
slope here is gonna be negative R if the
slope up here is going to be a plus B
the slope would be negative a plus B so
you know that you would have to have two
answers that are the negative of each
other so when you look at just the
choices you could have said oh it's
either gonna be a and because of the
negative of their their negatives of
each other or it's going to be C and D
so you could have ruled out you could
have either just picked these two or
these two so you had a 50-50 chance of
guessing but we don't want to guess we
want to solve it and we just did anyway
hopefully you enjoyed that